lkw fahren knochenjob und leidenschaft
zugleich medien reinfried und pete sind
trucker aus überzeugung auch wenn dieser
job einiges verlangt ständiger zeitdruck
und immer ärger im verkehrschaos
hektik kommt auf wenn das wohlverdiente
wochenende ansteht
aber heute ist das ein bisschen was
anderes
pa rapid bleibt auch im urlaub nichts
erspart
[Musik]
balance akt ihrer mutter und trainerin
medien die sehnsucht nach ihrem sohn
livio stimmt sie nachdenklich
wenn ich sowas sehe dann wenn man
vielleicht doch schon gerne auch dabei
stress hinterm steuer der ganz normale
alltag der trucker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für reinfried genannte easy beginnt der
arbeitstag früh zwei and ladestationen
und eine beladen stelle muss er heute an
steuern
er hat es eilig wie immer doch heute
will er pünktlicher denn je ans ziel
kommen
im fränkischen wörnitz findet ein
trucker event der besonderen art statt
reinfried engagiert sich im verein
bewegen mit herz die schwacke
organisieren einen lkw konvoi für kinder
und jugendliche aus sozialen
einrichtungen in heilbronn muss sie
jetzt abladen an den verladerampen sind
lange wartezeiten keine seltenheit wenn
er heute pünktlich feierabend machen
will muss alles reibungslos verlaufen
[Musik]
rampe 3 gehört easy
doch ein anderer fahrer hat sich
vorgedrängelt sie nimmt's leicht lässt
gnade vor recht ergehen wenn ein großer
wäre ich würde sagen sie zu dass dieser
weg wird die rampe ist für mich viel
erfahren über eine voll ist aus meiner
sicht auch im klang
kriegst du dann
nach kurzer wartezeit dann das nächste
problem
wo ist der lieferschein
mal gucken bei den paletten sieht man
normalerweise innerhalb der crew der
lieferschein tasche wenn man den leaf
wahrscheinlich gleich hat das dauert
halt etwas länger auch für den fahrer
weil wenn man den lieben haben müssen
wir erst noch einmal bearbeiten und dann
muss er halt ein paar minuten noch
warten bis er weiter kann das hat gerade
noch gefehlt zusätzlichen papierkram
kann sie gar nicht gebrauchen
[Musik]
da nix da ist nichts dass er lieber sein
ja die erste palette die aufgeladen
wurde
für sie kann es weitergehen
[Musik]
wie wir in blumenthal seit über einem
jahr ist die ehemalige krankenschwester
als lkw fahrerin auf deutschen straßen
unterwegs
wir wären ist mutter der dreijährigen
evo ist bei seinem vater oder bei
gewinns eltern wenn sie wochentags auf
dem bock unterwegs ist bei ihrer familie
kann sie nur an wochenenden sein wenn er
nicht wieder ein stau dazwischen kommt
oder wie wir ihn von ihrem disponenten
eine samstags tour aufgebrummt bekommt
woche für woche grüezi schafft sie es
freitags rechtzeitig in den feierabend
zu kommen
stressig wird das erst zum ende der
woche hin
wenn man dann weiß irgendwie irgendwo
man donnerstag laden muss
und wo ist dann hingeht und man ist dann
irgendwie von donnerstag zu freitag noch
irgendwie nach regensburg und da geht es
ja schon klar dass man nicht irgendwie
zeit ich nach hause kommen
denn er hat mich das schon so ein
bisschen ja dann bin ich sogar etwas
traurig haben wollten
ich meinen prinzen waren auch schon sehr
vermissen
bwin als zeitdruck in doppelter hinsicht
ihre kunden wollen pünktlich geliefert
werden und gleichzeitig ist es ein kampf
gegen die uhr früh genug am freitag in
den feierabend zu kommen
serbien hat lattenroste geladen die sie
an mehrere kunden in ostwestfalen an
liefern muss lattenroste für die beim
hausarzt abliefern sollen
gretchen imbiss normalerweise beliefert
vivien discounter mit lebensmitteln
hätten teile sind eher ungewöhnlich vor
einer stunde ist vivien einen teil der
ware bei anderen kunden bereits
losgeworden
für diese möbel firma ist der rest der
fracht bestimmt doch offenbar gibt es
ein problem
[Musik]
diese firma trifft keine schuld
der vorherige kunde hat irrtümlich nicht
alle lattenroste end lagen
jetzt haben wir wieder eine stunde die
wir zurückblicken können die mir nachher
am ende fehlt noch
manche sind einfach unfähig ehrlich das
sind so momente dann hast du auch keinen
bock mehr gerade kurzzeitig weil es
einfach nervt es hilft nichts
wie wir muss die vergessene ware
schnellstens loswerden und noch einmal
zum kunden fahren
ein umweg von einer stunde der
folgeauftrag wartet schon
und diese hat es in sich wie ins
disponent meint es heute nicht gut mit
ihr
[Musik]
ja gut okay
das ist nun dass meine schönsten nichts
gar nichts kurz vor dem wochenende muss
medien von hamm nach gundelfingen im
breisgau 500 kilometer hin und wieder
zurück dann 500 kilometer mit dem auto
richtung heimat
[Musik]
das emsland
lkw-fahrer pete ist seit fünf stunden
auf den beinen
auch er hat es heute noch eiliger als
sonst einen kurzurlaub steht bevor
pitt hat so genannte layer geladen
glasfaser schläuche für die
rohrsanierung kurzfristig hat ihn sein
disponent zu seiner spedition nach
rheine gelotst um zusätzliche ware auf
zulagen
es riecht nach ärger
ich weiß nicht mit einer lagerfläche
aussieht jawohl ich hab ja sechs große
liner drauf demnach mutter kriegt gute
frage was heißt kusel einer schwere als
dass diese heben kann
2,6 von der ganzen scheiße ist wieder
ablagen oder was bewegen kam drauf zu
kriegen
pitts knöpft sich den disponenten vor
sowohl in einer kiste lassen wenn ich
mal fragen
erst nach zwei jahren pause 22 einsätzen
tja wenn ihr mir das vorher einer gesagt
hätte hätte ich die paletten ja
zusammenstellen könnte ich hab jetzt
vornehmen anhänger zwei pakete paletten
und von der maschine zwei pakete
paletten weil man das feuer wieder
keiner gesagt hat dass ich noch lange zu
laden muss jetzt kann man den ganzen
scheiß auf machen und alle sorgen
abladen dann richtig schatzkiste der
widerruf riegels recht und claudia
fahrer und ihre disponenten
nicht selten kommt es zu reibereien ein
kleiner fehler in der kommunikation kann
eine halbe stunde zeitverlust nach sich
ziehen
es passiert im täglichen geschäft man
muss man mal lächeln
die fünf gerade werden lassen wir sagt
er wieder keiner was jetzt können wir
den 24
umlagen man ja auch nichts besseres zu
tun als bei der wärme so was nervt mich
dann zur wiedergutmachung packt der chef
höchstpersönlich mit an
trotzdem eine halbe stunde zeitverlust
lässt sich so schnell nicht wieder
heraus fahren
die spezialisierte verfügungseinheit der
polizeidirektion hannover ist
tonnenschweren verkehrssündern auf der
spur die kommissare sascha möbius und
volker skerka sind auf der a2 unterwegs
einer der lkw routen deutschlands
wir haben hier sehr sehr viel
schwerlastverkehr weil deutschland auch
einen transit land ist osteuropa
erfahren rüber nach westeuropa und auch
wieder zurück und das verkehrsaufkommen
und somit auch die unfallhäufigkeit ist
hier leider sehr hoch
der anteil an osteuropäischen fahrzeugen
nimmt stetig zu
die gründe für mangelhafte laster aus
billiglohnländern wiegen für
polizeioberkommissar monroe views auf
der hand wenn man einen extrem günstigen
preis anbietet dann muss dass von
irgendwoher kommen da muss man irgendwo
anders sparen denn das ist oftmals an
den fahrzeugen
an den charme aber auch die osteuropäer
werden immer besser moderne sieht man an
der zugmaschine das ist ein relativ
neuer volvo volkers kerker ist speziell
geschult im bereich fahrzeug und
ladungssicherheit sein kollege sascha
möbius ist experte für die aufklärung
von manipulationen an den fahrzeugen
jeder kilometer jede gefahrene minute
diese geschwindigkeitsüberschreitung und
auch jede kontrolle durch die behörden
werden im tachometer festgehalten
die haben ja mal ein verstoß über eine
minute besser zu lang gelenkt hat einmal
über acht minuten und einmal eine
ruhezeit um zwei minuten verkürzt ich
kontrolliere hier 29 tage da sind
minimal verstöße und bei sowas wirklich
mal auge zu ich suche besucher wandern
schwerwiegendere sachen er fährt gerne
mal zügig das werde ich mit ihm einmal
4,7 das war fast eine vollbremsung die
aber aus irgendwelchen gründen hingelegt
hat ich meine ich hier autobahn profil
und dann stauende wahrscheinlich sehr
spät gesehen dass sich nämlich nach
einer gefahrenbremsung aus und er sieht
man auch dass es dann hier relativ
langsam weiter geht so mit 10 12 km h
und das ist ein klassischer fall nicht
aufpassen und dann entweder kraft oder
er legt so wie hier eine vollbremsung
hin
für zu schnelles fahren muss der
russische trucker strafe zahlen
100 euro hat er dabei sascha möbius
belässt es bei einer verminderten strafe
von 50 euro
weil alles will ich genau nicht aus der
tasche ziehen muss sich verpflegen er
muss duschen vielleicht muss er noch in
anderen ländern das ein oder andere
bestechungsgeld zahlen wir reden hier
von osteuropa in russland und da ist das
halt mal ganz anders und das kriege ich
so häufig fanfaren zu hören ja das geld
brauche ich noch für ganz andere zwecke
wenn sie verstehen was ich meine
bei easy geht es schleppend voran
der grund meine baustelle eine von
derzeit rund 430 in deutschland straßen
müssen definitiv gemacht werden was was
mich nervt es dass der baustellen sind
wo gar nicht gebaut wird dass sie
wochenlang dastehen und dann wird nichts
gemacht zu den baustellen kommen
überfüllte parkplätze
nach viereinhalb stunden fahrzeit muss
sie eine vorgeschriebene pause machen
doch es herrscht parkplatznot auf
deutschen autobahnen
einige kollegen stellen sich aus
verzweiflung sogar auf den
seitenstreifen
nach zwei anläufen findet ihr endlich
einen freien platz
die sie braucht jetzt koffein
instantkaffee vom campingkocher die
verpflegung von den meisten raststätten
verschmähte ja schon lange
[Musik]
das führt zu teuer 23 akw auf
rastplätzen begegnete sie immer öfter so
genannten polen sprintern diese
kleintransporter erobern den markt